lamnet is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a sadakajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to allah through your donation
you want to shall be rewarded click the
link and donate what you can
what happened today better cartoon
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well in charlotte so
we're going to get straight into it so
we've got this absolute clown an
ignorant ignoramus
clown that's
let's go straight into inshallah here he
is talking about islam and how violent
it is we're going to educate him and not
only that we're going to educate him
about his own bible the reality is
according to islam's most trusted
sources those who do not believe in
allah and his messenger muhammad are by
default now infidels okay the word
infidel comes from christianity by the
way just to let you know let's carry on
and how did muhammad deal with enemies
of the faith so when you meet those who
disbelieve smite at their next till you
have killed and wounded many of them
then bind and bond firmly on them i.e
take them as captives thereafter is the
time either for generosity to free them
without ransom or ransom hold on a
second i thought we were supposed to
kill them by default why would you let
them go by ransom or just let them go
are we not meant to kill the infidels
wherever we find them why would you let
them go now according to what benefits
islam until the war lays down at the
burden
thus you are ordered by allah to
continue in carrying out jihad against
the disbelievers till they embrace islam
so allah saying until war lays down its
burdens meaning in other words you know
you carry out this until they stop
attacking is a war until war calms down
but i thought we're the ones who spotted
starting the war surah baqarah verse 2 5
6 there is no compulsion in religion
truth has become distinct from falsehood
i thought was supposed to kill everybody
do you see my context is so important no
compulsion religion this can be debunked
with one verse in sort of chapter 16
verse 8 sort of time in verse 8 allah
does not forbid you from being just
unkind to those who do not fight you
account of your faith and kick you out
from your household he only orders you
to fight those who have attacked you
this false notion that we are supposed
to kill and fight the disbelievers where
we find them is absolutely nonsense do
you see why context is so important
because i've studied more and more about
islam
you studied islam
let's carry on what the hell this guy
smoking crack i've come to see that
muhammad had a very interesting
relationship with decapitation in fact
he affirmed beheading as a legitimate
means of punishment sorry my bad you
know they should use an electric chair
maybe poisoning um what else was that
sorry man how else are you meant to
execute somebody back in those days have
committed treason or war or tried to
kill innocent people what are you
supposed to do pat him on the head hey
mate just one example muhammad in his
interactions with the jewish tribe and
see what he chose to do to understand
the context of mohammed's mass
extermination and enslavement first we
must look at the battle of trench in 627
a.d leading up to the battle over a
period of several years muhammad had
been conducting raids on meccan trade
routes with his gang of companions this
is an absolute lie this guy's an
absolute ignoramus clown [ __ ]
sent a group of companions to go and
observe basically get intelligence of
what the meccans are doing when they
went there they saw the the meccans
carrying a caravan and bear in mind they
have been kicked up their houses and
been persecuted and killed so they are
there and they are their own belongings
things that belong to them but what they
did what they did is they got into an uh
a war with the caravan uh some of the
quraish died and some of the companions
died when they came back to the prophet
muhammed the prophet peace be upon him
and rebuked them and said i never asked
you to fight
yes you said let me ask you if i want
you to go there and get intelligence do
you get i'm trying to say and for why
because then fighting in the holy month
was not forbidden but allah corrects
that and says yes that is wrong but what
they're doing by persecuting you guys
and kicking you out is far worse this
had driven the meccans to their wits end
and they had finally decided that they
had enough they were going to wipe islam
off the map gosh look at this sobbing
story let's look at some verses which
clarify what the meccans were doing yeah
let's let's go through this and let's
just let's clarify all of this here so
we can educate this little boy this
little child this little kid do you see
my context it's so important surah
39-40 this was the first permission
given to the muslims after 13 years of
persecution or being killed and kicked
out their houses let's see what it says
you know these
these quraish the pagans had enough you
know because the muslims were doing so
much let's see what they were doing
permission to fight has been given to
those who are being fought permission
given now because they've been fought
because they were wrong they are the
ones who have been evicted from their
homes without right only because they
say our lord is allah do you see why
context is so important surah anfal
verse 56 those of whom you took a pledge
but every time they dishonor their
pledge and they do not fear they break
their treaty and plot against the
muslims over and over again do you see
why context is so important surah and 5
verse 36 those who have disbelieved and
spent their wealth to hinder the power
of allah meaning not only do they
disbelieve they are collecting money and
resources to attack the muslims do you
see what context is so important surah
anfal verse 30 and remember muhammad
when those who disbelieve plotted
against you to restrain you or kill you
or evict you from mecca but they plan
and allah is the best of planets
planning to execute the prophet muhammad
for what preaching islam do you see my
context is so important
verse 26 i remember when you were few
and oppressed in the land oppressed in
the land fearing that people might
abduct you but he sheltered you
supported you with his victory do you
see my context is so important
verse 10 talking about the battle of
change we're going to come to when they
came against you from above you from
below you when the sight swerved and the
hearts reached the floor and you were
conjecture meaning the companions were
so scared because the quraysh was in
front of them the hypocrites were
plotting pretending to be muslims
plotting against them the jews who
brought the treaty which were going to
come to in a minute to educate the
little boy as well do you see my context
it's so important so ramadan verse 11
all you who believe remember the favor
of allah upon you when the people
determined to try to kill you against
you but he would uh he protected you do
you see why context is so important
verse 19 to 91 and if allah would he
could have given them power over you and
they would afford you if they remove
themselves from you and do not fight
offer peace who's transgressing here do
you see my context is so important so
verse 19 194 fight in the way of allah
those who fought you but do not
transgress killing innocent men women
and children verse 91 and kill them
wherever you overtake them let's carry
on reading and expel them from wherever
they have expelled you and do not fight
at the masjid al-haram but if they fight
you there kill them the meaning kill
them wherever you overtake them and
expel them because whether they've
expelled you so meaning from the get-go
they were starting the killing and from
the get-go they were expelling the
muslims while saying do not fight in the
holy mosque but if they fight you their
meaning if they're going to transgress
that as well fight them there also do
you see why context is so important
surah imam verse 195 so those who
emigrated or evicted from their homes or
were harmed in my cause of four or four
over killed i will surely remove them
from them their mysteries and surely
admit them into paradise immigrated and
evicted from their homes and harmed and
killed ah poor little meccans aren't
they do you see my context it's so
important and the verses go on and on so
you can see very clearly the persecution
the killing the murder the the attacks
all came
from the quraysh so the way this clown
little uneducated ignoramus is making it
out to be is like the quraysh was just
like innocent they were not doing
nothing and the muslims are keeping
attacking you brought the absolute
ignoramus liar the muslims adopted a
trench strategy which actually worked
very well in their favor in keeping the
upwards of twelve thousand meccans at
bay that wasn't comparison of muhammad's
only three thousand jihadis and medinans
not including the jewish tribe of
ganesha can you imagine this you're
being persecuted killed attacked you're
in a war zone where there's twelve
thousand um uh quraysh there you've got
the moon african the hypocrites who are
pretending to be muslims who are
backstabbing you and then you've got the
uh the the jews who have broken the
treaty and this pusillanimous weasel i'm
so sorry guys this is an uneducated
clown yeah energy clown is here calling
three thousand muslims who are feeling
for their life calls them jihadis you
know what if you bloody clown you bloody
clown sources say that some of the jews
appealed to the polytheists to try to
get rid of muhammad all together and
when he found this out he didn't like
that long story short when the meccans
saw that the trend strategy was working
they were eventually forced to give up
and abandon the area leaving the jews at
the area alone with over three thousand
jihadis that had just taken the land
three thousand jihadis are just just
taking the land because you can't make
this crop up man so now here is where it
gets extremely interesting when eliza
apostle returned on the day of battle of
alhandak i.e the trench he put down his
arms and took a bath then gabriel whose
head was covered with dust came to him
saying you have put down your arms by
allah i have not put down my arms yet
eliza apostle said where to go now
gabriel said this way pointing to the
tribe of bani tribe gorezia so allah's
apostle went out towards them so hold on
a second if the prophet peace be upon
him is blood thirsty you can see he he
didn't want to even take retribution
unless a divine commandment came so that
nullifies your point that the prophet
peace be upon him he actually was he
left it at that but no the divine just
commandment came and he did what was
right so as i said the jews were taking
they did not want the fight they did not
want to battle with muhammad and in a
moment of desperation they called for a
bullab who was a nominal muslim who had
worked with muhammad in some capacity
but had also opposed him at certain
points and they basically asked him for
advice and they said hey how can we
handle this situation so that we walk
away with our lives and let's check out
his answer
then the question said to the apostle
saying send us
that we may consult him so the apostle
sent into them and when they saw him
they got up to meet him the women and
children went up to him weeping in his
face and he felt sorry for them they
said oh abu baba do you think we should
submit to muhammad's judgment he said
yes and pointed with his hands to his
throat signifying slaughter now despite
this warning the jews still decided to
submit to muhammad out of desperation
and this is when muhammad did something
extremely sinister muhammad offered to
have them submit not to the judgment of
himself but to one from the tribal house
now this police of jews because
historically the tribe of mouse had had
many alliances with the jews in the past
and so they saw this as an opportunity
to get some type of leniency that was
until they saw who mohammed appointed to
give the judgment their hopes were
dashed to pieces when they saw the
muhammad show sad bin wad this is a lie
uh and one thing we're going to educate
our timothy's pigeon-hearted weasel here
when kharava had allies uh with saddam
in
sardinia's tribe
so they
actually were rejoiced when they asked
when they chose sad ibn muhat him and
his tribe was our allies so they were
like yes sad ibn muad is the perfect
person so it's a lie that the prophet
muhammad picked him no the quran quran
picks out even what let's carry on what
happened next who was a tribe leader of
aoes who hated the jews and so this
makes his next statement about the
judgment not that surprising when the
tribe of quraysh was ready to accept
saad's judgment allah's apostle sent
forsad who was near to him sad came
riding a donkey and when he came near
allah's apostle said to the assad or
helpers stand up for your leader then
sad came and sat beside eliza apostle
who said to him these people are ready
to accept your judgment assad said i
give the judgment that their warriors
should be killed and their children and
women should be taken as prisoners the
prophet then remarked oh sod you're
judged amongst them with or similar to
the judgment of the king allah so hold
on a second
was ready to accept such judgment i
thought they won't they
before they were happy i thought they
were coerced
yeah i thought they were coerced
quraydha was ready to accept such
judgment this is totally debunking our
claim then the question surrendered and
the apostle can find them in medina in
the corner of hadith then the apostle
went out to the market in medina which
is still its market today and dug
trenches in it then he sent for them and
struck off their heads in those trenches
as they were brought out to him in
batches there were 600 or 700 in all
though some put the figure as high as
800 or 900 as they were being taken out
in batches to the apostle they asked ab
what they thought would be done with
them he replied will you never
understand don't you see that the
summoner never stops and those who are
taken away do not return by allah it is
death they went on until the apostle
made an end of them i mean he's given
the numbers at six seven eight hundred
man there should be no problem if that
was in the thousands
now how
let's put this into context
america has uh is allies with the united
kingdom and they are going to well with
russia
when they are going to war with russia
let's suppose russia is the transgressor
even though we know america is actually
tranquilizer and you know all the time
most of the times anyways so when that
is happening
united kingdom backstabs america and
gets
becomes allies with russia
what do you think america would do in
that state would they send the letter
saying united kingdom you have deeply
broken our heart we trusted you but
anyways let's carry on
the health what planet do you live on
well hold on a second actually let's put
everything inside of him right to a side
let's put the prophet muhammad peace be
on to our side let's put the angel
gabriel to a side let's put the quran to
a side let's go to the bible youtube
chapter 20 verse 10 to 14. well hold on
a second i know i know it's the old
testament oh my bad jesus is the god of
the god of the old testament right all
right let's carry on reading what jesus
stipulated now if the city will not make
peace with you but make war against you
then you shall besiege it number one and
when the lord your god delivers into
your hands you should strike every male
in it with the edge of your sword so
they're not snap district another but
the woman
the little ones little ones untrained
ones college students like you the
livestock and all that is in the city
it's spoiled shall plunder for yourself
it's the bible mate this is the bible
and now let's put the bible to a side
the point is this treachery and if that
happens with united kingdom america
there will be capital punishment because
that is treason and the men will be
executed it's as simple as that and the
prophet peace be upon him had a pact
with them a treaty with the jews that if
a common enemy comes the muslims will
defend the jews and the same should be
done when the quraysh came useful
they're going to finish them so let's
join forces and broke the treaty and
that is capital punishment so not
beheading of 600 6 000 or 600 000 it's
all justified do you see why context is
so important now you know what's funny
is that this guy making the prophet
peace be upon him like some kind of a
false prophet or whatever just because
of that may if that's the case you can
say
goodbye to your bible and your jesus
goodbye jesus of the old testament if
you look at it he is ordered the killing
of men women children babies donkeys
broth brother what did the donkey do
i've been asking this question for the
past 10 years what the hell did the
donkey or the baby do what did they do
if you look at your scriptures there is
killing show me any verse in the quran
hadith that orders a direct killing of
innocent men women children or babies
and you want to talk about jewish
persecution
my friend go damn look at your history
you christians have
massacred persecuted everybody when it
came to the jews because they killed
your god yes jesus you didn't leave them
alone in history you have massacred jews
at a level which you cannot even dare to
question islam and we know of chief
rabbi of edna um isaac
sarfati here in the land of the turks we
have nothing to complain of we possess
great fortune much golden silver in our
hands we are not oppressed with heavy
taxes and our commerce is free and
unhindered rich are the fruits of the
earth everything is cheap and every one
of us live in peace and freedom here the
jew is not compelled to wear a yellow
hat as a badge of shame as in the case
of germany where even wealth and great
fortune are cursed for a jew because of
uh because he therewith arouses jealousy
among the christians and they devise all
kinds of standard against him and rob
him with his gold arise my brothers gird
up your loins collect your forces and
come to us here you will be free of your
enemies here you will find rest letter
to persecuted jews living in central
europe and there was a rabbi who said if
the muslims were ruling
at the time where hitler was the hitler
was we would have had 6 million extra
jews today i hope this has been an
educational lesson for you you're
absolutely liar yeah you're supposed to
be a christian yeah thou shalt not lie
you've been educated and scooped yes
okay and i gave you a great f fail yes
fail
so till next time assalamu alaikum